[Music]
hello there good evening you're watching
the press preview it's the first look at
what is on the front pages as they
arrive in the next half an hour we're
going to be seeing what is making the
headlines that's with the journalist and
author rachel shabby and columnist at
the article ali mirage
well let's see what is on some of those
front pages all of the papers as you
might expect are leading on the invasion
of ukraine
the times has a picture of people taking
cover in kiev as an air raid siren
sounds with the headline
terror stalks the streets
the sunday telegraph says fierce
resistance by the ukrainians has slowed
down the russian advance into their
country
and the star has a picture of ukraine's
president who has vowed to stay and
fight
the mirror says the ukrainians have
managed to hold on to their capital city
despite the presence of russian troops
on the outskirts
fight to the death is the headline for
the sun and the express says ukraine's
forces have won praise from ministers
and even members of the royal family
have expressed their support for the
people of ukraine
freedom fighters that is how the people
describes the ukrainian forces
and vladimir putin is facing growing
isolation that's as many former allies
have turned against him that is on the
front of the observer a reminder that by
scanning the qr code that you can see on
the screen during the program you can
also check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
well tonight we are joined by rachel
shabby and ali miraj a very good evening
to both of you before we start getting
into the front pages really i just want
to get a reflection
from both of you perilous times in
ukraine the people in the capital city
including many
journalists many sky news journalists as
well
waiting the city administration has
sounded an alert there
unknown and perilous times ahead your
reflections rachel
it's absolutely horrifying to watch i
think for all of us um watching these
scenes um it's just
appalling to see this happen in ukraine
to see a nation be
terrorized by a military invasion in
this way is
deeply upsetting
and just you know
heart goes out to people who are
living in these conditions facing this
appalling bombardment from russia
um
and also having to flee their own
country we've seen
you know thousands upon thousands of
people
desperate to leave the country um you
know women children
long queues a long queue of people
leaving
seeking refuge in poland
obviously
we have a responsibility now
to keep our borders open
to anybody who needs them at this
horrendous time
ali your thoughts on war in europe
well it's a
a very very poignant moment
and our thoughts and prayers
and good wishes are with hysterical
people of ukraine who are
by for all intents purposes mounting
quite a quite a fight uh which is in
really stark contrast i mean look
vladimir zielenski is a comedian well
he's leading from the front uh here and
you can't help contrast the way he's
behaving with the approach taken by
ashraf ghani the president of
afghanistan last year when as the
taliban were closing in on kabul
scalpered in a plane allegedly with
oodles of cash a claim which he denies
the contrast could not be more stock so
very very difficult times as rachel said
i passed the uh the russian embassy uh
earlier today and a lot of solidarity
there
and thoughts for the people of ukraine
rachel let's look at the front page of
the sunday telegraph fierce resistance
slows putin's advance in ukraine it's a
pretty dogged resistance isn't it being
put up not just by ukrainian military
but by by normal people civilians
yeah that's absolutely right and if you
know the reports are that putin was
expecting a sort of lightning invasion
well that's not what this is and that's
because um in no small part to this huge
resistance as you say
uh civilian as well as military um
outsmart outsmarting putin's um forces
um very sort of nifty scrappy civilian
operation um seems to be outwitting
russian troops and tanks um diverting
them so that um you know ensuring that
they get lost um thwarting them
uh russian uh forces themselves are also
not doing a great job apparently
needing to be refueling
more than they need to be
and
not managing to do this
swift invasion that perhaps putin had
hoped for so it is yeah absolutely
extraordinary and it does seem to be
just
regular people
um getting engaged in this we saw
earlier scenes of just
people who normally would be working
nine to five packing molotov cocktails
by day now and it has to be said that
this is this is what resistance looks
like um we're seeing it in ukraine but
of course this is what happens in other
countries as well
that face an illegal military invasion
of this sort yeah ali
vladimir putin won't have figured on
this not going
to plan will he particularly not when
you consider the might of the russian
military
well the russians have been building up
their military forces uh for the past
decade and they've also been trying to
insulate themselves from the effects of
sanctions as well
but vladimir putin looks like he's got a
fight on his hands i still think it's
going to be difficult for the ukrainians
to
resist this indefinitely although we
wish them the very best and uh they're
fighting very very hard and what the
west can do is to
provide arms and provide whatever
support it can in terms of punitive
sanctions to the people of ukraine
uh but yes certainly it's not going
exactly to plan for putin but ultimately
he has got
an air force as well on top of this now
that may not be as useful in
hand-to-hand kind of combat in cities uh
we'll have to wait and see
but the west should do whatever it can
sure to putting boots on the ground
itself
to support the people of ukraine um
ukrainian media rachel reporting that an
er that an air attack is imminent on the
capital city
tonight
uh the front
page of the sun says simply fight
to the death
you know it's really really hard i mean
i'm not a ukraine expert i should say
that up front but just talking
to the geopolitics of this i mean i
think ali signposted that a moment ago
that you know we are looking at russia
is a huge military
force nuclear-powered force ukraine is
not
um now
it's not a nato member and we are not
nobody is sending troops to help fight
so that being the case i mean of course
absolute solidarity with ukraine
but it is also hard to see how this ends
quickly i think what we're looking at is
what we often look at when we see a
military invasion we saw it in iraq we
saw it in afghanistan is that people
resist of course they do nobody wants to
be occupied
palestinians certainly don't want to be
occupied
resistance is what happens but
it also can be a very long drawn-out
affair and i don't say that with any
satisfaction that that this may actually
drag on for a while
ali let's talk about the front page
of the star we won't run and hide of
course some of the most powerful
testimony and there has been a lot of it
hasn't there since this started a mere
three days ago
has come from president zielenski
himself he said president biden offered
him a way out of the country he said i
don't want to ride
i need ammunition
yeah very untypical for the us to be
dealing with someone who actually has
got the guts and the courage to stand
and fight and lead his people in that
direction highly untypical for them uh
given their recent experience
particularly as i mentioned in
afghanistan but look uh vladimir
zelinski uh is not only leading from the
front uh i saw him with a a rifle
earlier but also posting
uh social media videos uh to try and
bolster his people to get the message
out to the outside world of exactly
what's going on the ground and also
conducting uh cool successive calls with
world leaders including boris johnson
who you thanked on twitter uh this
evening so he's uh he's doing well in
the uh in the communication stakes as
well as leading from the front but i
think
uh rachel touched on the geopolitics of
this and i think there are really two
points there are a wake-up call for the
west here uh the first is that we over
the last
30-yard year since the since the end of
the cold war have really not invested
enough in defense if you look at uk
defense spending we spend about four
percent in 1989 on defence we now spend
about two percent of gdp on it
could say the same for the nato allies
who are really uh admonished by
president trump of all people about not
spending enough on nato's defense and
the second thing is we've been all
caught with our
uh a little bit um napping here sleep at
the wheel not so much the uk but
certainly germany and parts of europe
who are very heavily dependent
on russia for their energy security uh
fifty percent of uh uh all oil and gas
imports into germany come from russia
and this is exactly why when it comes to
sanctions the energy sector has been
excluded from sanctions because large
parts of europe have got no choice but
to take russian gas and that is a
strategic error that has been made which
we're now paying the price for and the
final thing to say is that
flirting flirting with uh ukrainian
membership of nato is the worst of all
worlds
nato allies uh back in 2008 ukraine
asked to be or put forward a request to
be a member of nato nato refused because
i had no desire to engage in a hot war
on the border with uh with russia
but now entertaining it is the worst of
all worlds you don't have the ukrainians
in nato and you don't have them outside
nato i mean it's just it's just a mess
at the moment quite frankly so i think
geopolitically we've got a lot of naval
gazing to do and we've got to really
kind of get real and strategically wean
ourselves off russian gas yeah i mean
you you talk about it being a mess there
ali uh rachel on the front of the sunday
times the foreign secretary liz trust
tells us that we need to prepare for 10
years
of conflict there is do you view it as
intractable as that
i think potentially yes and
look i pray i'm wrong i'm not a ukraine
expert and i pray that i've got this
really wrong and that it is swift
um but we are looking at a dynamic that
doesn't suggest that ukraine
is an independent country it does not
deserve and did not ask to be caught in
a crossfire
of you know a kind of glo uh cold war
rehash
um
you know but it but it is
unfortunately has been dragged into this
geopolitical situation and
i agree with ali to some extent that
it's to do with um
western dependency on gas and oil from
russia but i think that's just a piece
in a bigger puzzle that's decades old um
that has made situations like this so
intractable we're looking at you know
russian oligarchs who fund our current
conservative government we're looking at
a new liberal system that has rewarded
um you know a sort of kleptocracy in
russia we're looking at a failing u.n
that is unable to prevent this sort of
thing we're looking at a failing nato
that has not acted
properly in the last 30 years
we're looking at terrible precedence of
invasion set by
western powers in iraq and afghanistan
it's all of that all of it together
that makes this
so so messy and so difficult
i mean
in terms of i mean the uk comes in for a
lot of criticism here doesn't it ali
about extricating itself from dependence
on russian money and oligarchs money and
the front page of the sunday mirror
uh features the story that broke this
evening about um roman abramovich
quitting
running chelsea was that your read of it
it's quite complicated statement what's
actually going on there with his
ownership just brief briefly
well it looks like uh
abramovic has been a very activist owner
of his football club over the last 19
years he takes an active interest in it
he's involved in the data they manage
management of it including uh appointing
managers and and also indeed uh player
decisions player hiring decisions as
well so he is very activist uh he sees
this as a way of protecting his own
football club but also potentially
protecting the fact
that he does not want his asset taken
away from him now as to what his
relationship is with putin i mean that's
something that will be determined in due
course but i think from his perspective
it's a sensible move to make he's put it
in the hands of the chelsea charitable
foundation so that the uh the football
club is not affected it's number three
in the premiership at the moment and
they're having a decent season uh
although one of their forwards has not
been performing up to a standard uh so
far uh so i think from his from his
perspective it's just a sensible move
okay all right rachel ally plenty more
for us to be talking about next hour so
we'll see you guys
we'll see you guys at half past 11.
thank you very much for now